and talk about people having sex
humanity and wanting to help others
especially there's all guys I think you
can have without organized religion so
what do you think people increase my
eternity of revolution when their life
by globalization seem to be much more
lead of choice and having liberty to
choose the way we do things the second
question is actually looking or dignity
for a bit too why you think the literal
translations have the investor to do
developing countries I'm thinking and I
think it's very firmly rooted in every
issues and the fact that the church is a
run organization that can promote a
certain ethnicity and have resources and
back you up which I don't necessarily
think is a good thing so aggressive
thing to hear right in there still have
such a strong industry well in relation
to the latter point I mean I think
you're right it can be like that and
that can also mean that it's bad I mean
I'm not saying that religion is except
Lee not saying religion is always a
force of good on the other hand it can
be also that it appeals to the same
things that it appeals to in in other
people it can be for other reasons too
but I think that for many people
professing faith in in in developing
countries and for those who are active
as as priests or Imams or those leading
their congregations actually they are
reflecting on some of these things and
prefer to seed now religion as an
instrument in society trying to help
society develop rather than that
actually promoting a particular
ethnicity but I mean I do work in Rwanda
where I mean tragically there were
people Christians who actually helped
perpetuate genocide so you know it is
possible yes it's possible but that's
part of what we should try and prevent I
mean the first point is very very good
point twitch my answer is it is
perfectly possible of course to be a
humanist
believe in these values too and there
are many people who are no faith at all
instead they and my foundation interacts
with them as well because so we should i
do live better lives and a lot of people
who profess religious faith that is
absolutely true the question you ask is
why is it when you could have that
without faith two people still feel this
and yearning towards spirituality and
that is because I think it is something
that's that's actually very much within
us and what is you know that that's
something that's just a judgment that
I'm making I may be wrong but but I
think what is interesting is that even
with all the science and the technology
and the theory of Darwin and the
knowledge that we have of the world
today actually spirituality as is not
diminished or the yearning for it now it
doesn't always coat it doesn't always
coincide with organized religion but it
it's still there and I think that's
because actually people understand
instinctively that simply what rules we
devised as human beings and simply our
interactions human beings is not enough
for us that's but I may be wrong